So the answer is, only the second and the third
are equivalent. This is a little surprising. This was kind
of a tricky question. So the reason the first one
is not, if x is seven or greater, well, then seven
mod seven has the value zero. That's not the same
as the x that we started with. And that's the
case also if we have eight. Eight module seven has
the value one. Which is different from what we started with.
When the modulo is greater than the possible value of
x, and we said, x could be only between zero and
10, well, then, the result is always the same as
x. The third question, when we map x to its character
value, and then we take the order of that, we'll
char an order inverses, so that's equivalent. You would think that
would in the other direction and the reason it doesn't is
because the input to ord must be a one letter string.
If the input's not a single character, then ord produces
an error. So let's see that in the Python interpreter, if
we print the result of ord where the input is a
number and we said x was a number between zero and
three. Well, that gives us an error. And it gives an
error, because ord expects a string of length one, but the
input was an integer. There is a function that allows us
to turn numbers into strings. And that's the str function that
takes a number and gives us a string corresponding
to that number. So let's see what str of three
gives us, that will give us the string three,
we can't see in output here that it is actually
a string, but it is a string, and we
can actually use order on the result there. When we
run this, what we get is 51, not the
three that we passed in and that's because the ord
of the character three is 51.